let's talk a bit about your own writing
as well your own comic strip because
obviously you've got one in Clint
magazine which you've got there I see
I've not seen this one yet as some
number seven
still no 77 pages of leox Royd I might
try to get to I think 110 for the book
and unless we actually makes perfect
sense to me and if you don't understand
it just come up and ask me yeah I'm
happy to explain what's happening this
one is about the annealing annie leonard
empire has taken over earth so this is
supposed to be a issue five of an alien
empire tape story and they've Tunde and
taken a nineteen fifties reality and rex
roid and everybody's been kind of
dampened down by this nineteen fifties
main control think there's one guy left
who is not taking on a kid detective it
was like an innate sort of Batman kinda
hybrid and it's not taking on him
because he's like schizophrenic
completely completely resistant act is
like that so he's just sitting at home
wondering what the [ __ ] wrong with our
culture well Rex Roy gradually twigs it
Azrael and retro is we have breaking the
kind of ill in Empire spell is to get
the scanner and appearance on I can
delete an eight-track sha well it turns
up and goes completely mate open it they
have to cut tear test card then it can
it can it breaks this bail but I don't
not many people are going to get that
from eating it but I'm really happy with
it where's the where do the ideas come
from for this these particular strips
and what kind of how would you describe
their style and they're supposed to be
kind of the idea was to be slightly more
poetic because I've only got eleven
pages a month so the idea was that it
would make a kind of poetic sense rather
than a strict kind of narrative sense um
and you know so the idea is like I feel
now like I live in a can a nineteen
fifties culture 11's really kind of you
know watch helium the Orton or something
nice I think well this could have been
well it's almost like alternative comedy
didn't happened and it's almost like you
could draw a line from a lot of what we
see now and
in general culture that would SCAP the
sixties amiss kept a lot the good stuff
in history um and I guess I feel a bit
like that guy so it's kind of like a
psychological although it seems really
weird the most weeks I think it's
actually queer kind of a obvious
psychological comic in a way of however
I'm feeling which is usually quite bad
is it like a bit like therapy then in a
way do you think totally well it's also
you find that as you rate and written
and as you work with your artist what
you're actually thinking at the time so
I had the idea for this story of and you
know we're les canaux nineteen fifties
world and it's kicking it does it
doesn't chain with what we've been
through
judo I mean so it's late we live in a
pre psychedelic age a pre sixties age
and and we don't and then and the story
just can develop some that how would you
like to see the how the how do you like
to see the strip continuing how do you
think it'll go on from here whatever I
just like it to go in for as long as
possible M it's a partly still is it
reacts Reuters can gradually realizing
that he's a comic book character he's
factional and they're eventually I
wanted to end up as a 4-step you know
like the old their doom or something art
where they're kind of cutting about as
real people here so we can we look
forward to any other kind of comic
creations from you in the future do you
think is this something that you've kind
of feels like a childhood ambition
fulfilled in a way octoly and I am by
London one more thing which is going to
be a sort of femme in a comedy ish
version of our final crisis type a
continuity event superhero thing I love
all those comics and I just loved it and
this is an extra kind of abandon to them
because you just accept that I've not
read the whole DC University of like and
through human once that's a [ __ ] line
and a suit is that correct on the comics
um well you just kind of accept that you
go with it anyway that you don't know
traditional connect superhero a reality
so I think there's a lot of potential
there for just doing a lot of quick path
their staff and creating some
superheroes can feel a lot of stuff I've
done in this has been like analogs of
things that already exist but
I begin today someone is this you able
to kind of edit the Clint a strip Rex
voyage for your kids so they can kind of
enjoy it or what what kind of age will
they be able to enjoy and you looking
forward to that moment I thought they'd
never see oh because it's actually about
them and me and stuff so that's let me
it supposed to be my kid and to start
this session it's badly drawn from a mic
in a relationship and feels for him
June I mean so I've taught that I've
taught that they would never get to see
that I think that day will come and they
will there what's that gonna be like
doing alright is pretty I'm actually
like really happy with I'm doing
critical of myself in general and there
you know I see you do things and I've
done things Michael you've got quite a
lot of Priya's final it didn't panel she
was just stuff like that what I've
actually thought you know what the work
here isn't actually that great you know
and that's the thing which gets almost
no reaction actually think between
myself and then the Arthur's messed up
tailing and am you know the work okay so
I'm just happy with that you happy to
continue kind of doing comics until the
end of time
sure sure that would be good if I had
enough ideas but I probably run out of
ideas
leerin a fantastic it's been great to
speak to you Frankie I know you've got a
real love of comic so it really comes
through and I hope the comic continues
go from strength to strength thanks a
lot chills nice to meet you
you